this is unbelievable what I'm about to
show you last month Donald Trump spoke
on the phone with the Filipino president
Rodrigo Duterte and he was widely
criticized by members of both parties
because he invited two Tara Tate to come
to the United States
Duterte is a violent strongman and we
now have a transcript of the call ok it
has been published in full by the
intercept we are going to go through
some aspects of this call and it is
incredibly disturbing let's start with
the first part of the transcript here if
we can path and you'll see that in this
after greeting each other uh Donald
Trump says that he I just want to
congratulate you because I'm hearing of
the unbelievable job on the drug problem
many countries have the problem we have
a problem but what and this is kind of
hard to see here what you were doing and
I just wanted to call and tell you that
it's what's great what you were doing
there's a confidential stamp over this
so it's hard to see it and the president
of the Philippines says thank you mr.
president this is the scourge of my
nation now and I have to do something to
preserve the Filipino nation and so at
the bottom then the president of the
United States says I understand that and
fully understand that and I think we had
a previous president who did not
understand that but I understand that
and we have spoken about this before
Donald Trump is within 30 seconds of
getting on the phone with Rodrigo
Duterte the president of another country
slamming Obama completely unprovoked
right saying the previous guy didn't
understand the problem of drugs
apparently of drug usage or drug dealing
it's not even clear what problem Obama
didn't understand but then he praises
Duterte for doing a great job on the war
on drugs people in the Philippines are
allowed and encouraged to kill suspected
drug dealers suspected and suspected
drug users in the streets with no
repercussions okay so let's continue
with the transcript of this phone call
between our fearless leader President
Trump and the President of the
Philippines Rodrigo Duterte okay so they
talk about a couple different things and
then they get onto kim jeong-hoon
okay so trump says what
your opinion of him Rodrigo are we
dealing with someone who is stable or
not stable this is a sort of rough
transcript and the President of the
Philippines says he is not stable mr.
president as he keeps what smiling when
he explodes a rocket he even has gone
against China which is the last country
that he should rebuke but it seems from
his face that he's laughing always and
there is a dangerous toy in his hands
which could create so much agony and
suffering for all mankind and this is
where it gets really wacky after they
talk a little bit about Kim jong-un at
the bottom of this page of the
transcript POTUS says we have a lot of
firepower over there we have two
submarines the best in the world we have
two nuclear submarines not what we want
to you not that we want to use them at
all
trump is again bragging about firepower
and talking about the strategic location
of American Navy assets he's bragging to
another president about about what we
have this is like when in the Oval
Office he was bragging to the Russian
the two Russian officials about the
great Intel that he gets that's what
Trump does when he gets on the phone
with a world leader brags about our
nuclear subs remember Trump said that he
would learn foreign policy on the job it
turns out to be true because during the
campaign he didn't even know about the
nuclear triad yeah now he knows about
the submarine now he knows at least that
the two submarines exist okay and then
lastly from this insane transcript
between Trump and Duterte
this is the infamous invitation okay
where Donald Trump said that you can
tell him let's see where did he say that
he's a good guy how he talks about how
he liked meeting the president of China
and then I think we have the second part
of this where Donald Trump actually
invites the president of the Philippines
to come to the yet to the u.s. saying we
will be happy to see you Rodrigo and I
look forward to seeing you if you want
to come to the Oval Office I will love
to have you in our Oval Office any time
you want to come I'll be in the
Philippines in November blah blah blah
blah blah that's the invitation that we
now learn
took place so a few interesting things
number one even when on the phone with
other presidents Trump brags about
nuclear power he he brags about weaponry
he slams Obama so Trump's conversations
with other world leaders seem to be the
same as basically what he says at a
campaign rally there seems to be no
difference in terms of decorum or
approach for Donald Trump and also what
was endlessly endlessly fascinating from
this is that Trump refers to the
President of the Philippines as Rodrigo
and the president of the Philippines
refers to Trump as mr. president that
might be that Trump just lacks decorum
and respect I don't know what we can
read into that maybe duterte is just
naturally more submissive in some way
but isn't this fascinating that we got
this transcript it really is because it
just sounds as if Trump has some sort of
man crush on duterte I mean when do we
get to meet each other November can we
do a little earlier your place my place
I'm all for it it's incredible truly
incredible and I was reading that with
endless fascination yesterday